a major interstate near Denver Colorado
is closed this morning as police
investigate a fiery crash that killed
multiple people and hospitalized six
others the flames incinerated vehicles
in Lakewood west of Denver yesterday it
took hours for the hot spots to cool
sufficiently for investigators to even
start working overnight this morning
front loaders are on the scene to clean
up all the debris officials say that
multiple people have died here but they
have not confirmed the exact number to
us yet
David Begnaud shows us how this crash
began one man recorded video as the
semi-truck allegedly responsible for the
crash barreled past his car on the
shoulder of i-70 moments later things
are exploding underneath this there is
fire the fire spread quickly devouring
cars and sending thick black smoke into
the air in Lakewood rush hour traffic
was already at a standstill
firefighters were working to put out the
flames that overtook all of the lanes of
the highway he smashed in my valor e
Robertson young saw the semi-truck speed
by that's her silver car on the side of
the highway four kids
15 grandkids so here at least a dozen
cars and three semis were involved in
the crash
Darren Barton helped to pull people to
safety there was couple other people
that was pretty banged up that uh
investigators will sift through debris
today looking for other victims the
driver of the semi truck that allegedly
caused the crash is among those
hospitalized it is true carnage there
this is is looking to be one of the
worst accidents we've had here in
Lakewood for CBS this morning I'm David
Beck no